US Navy submarine missing for 75 years
has been found off Okinawa Japan the USS
Grayback had sailed out of Pearl Harbor
on January 28 1944 for its tenth combat
patrol and it never came back two months
later it was listed as missing and
presumed lost and remained lost its
location was unknown until last year an
amateur researcher in Japan detected a
mistake in the latitude and longitude of
the spot where the Grayback was possibly
down he was off by one digit it was a
mistranslation of the original Japanese
and now earlier this year using that new
information private explorers were able
to locate the wreck 1,400 feet under the
surface of the water this is important
on this day in particular because 80
families who lost the service person on
that on that submarine this is closure
yes you now know what happened and you
know where the final resting place was
and there will presumably be a process
of repatriation if you just think what a
difference that one number may be
careful